clark county school district is
reporting more than a thousand positive
cases since july first more than half of
those cases are students this week 55
more people tested positive for the
coronavirus and nearly half of all cases
are in elementary elementary schools
children under 12 are not eligible for
the coronavirus vaccine to help fight
the virus ccsd is using new uvc
sanitizing light technology there you
see the device there it's called the arc
the hospital grade uvc light destroys
99.9 percent of pathogens on surfaces
and in the air just takes seven minutes
all schools in the district are going to
get one of the are going to get one of
those and the district is working on a
schedule to have each classroom cleaned
at least once a week
there's no silver bullet that's going to
put us in a position where we don't have
to have a layered strategy this is one
tool in our layer strategy for
virus mitigation
staff plan to use those devices in
restrooms and health offices every day
and a few rooms each evening because the
light can also remove the flu and the
common cold e coli norovirus other
viruses essentially ccsd plans to keep
using it after the pandemic